now a true-crime comedy show may sound a
little strange a whole lot of strange
but fans of my favorite murders say
there's something strange about it it's
so much more than just a podcast is what
they say my favorite murder is hosted by
Karen kill Gareth and Georgia hardstark
it averages listen to this number two
million listeners for episode Wow and 30
million downloads a month the hosts
willingness to share their personal
lives with listeners has created a
legion of devoted fans who dress up like
them I think that's a little strange get
tattoos of their slogans and turn up in
huge numbers for their live shows their
new book as a joint memoir it's called
stay sexy and don't get murdered the
definitive how-to guide Karen and
Georgia both join us at the table as
they point out this is the first
three-on-two interview they've had so
get ready here all I like first we
should say hello murder Eno's because
that's what you call yourselves and
people who like this genre
now you said you two bonded over your
love for this subject and Brene brown
karen you start how does that mean well
we were at a very uncomfortable dinner
party that was too small to be like you
know loud and boisterous and the tension
was kind of building and in the middle
of it Georgia just went let's all go
around the table and say what we feel
most vulnerable about well everyone else
went totally silent and across the room
I was like are you reading brené Brown
right now just screamed at her and that
was our first bonding moment I would
yeah I would say that was Thanksgiving
yes there's like a friendsgiving that
we're at when did you discover you both
like murder you've liked it for a long
time Jordan about crime yeah we've both
been obsessed but like secretly because
it's kind of a taboo subject right
people look at you like you're little
weird that's right so you don't talk
about it much so when she Karen I saw
her at a Halloween party she brought up
a like a horrible event and the party
started to kind of scatter walk away
across the room I was like tell me every
single detail how did you turn that
decide to turn this into the
crowd-pleasing podcast yeah we're still
wondering that actually
was there a moment you said hey this is
a great idea for a podcast how did that
happen I mean I think we both we both
always loved true crime and it's always
been on I mean like Forensic Files
there's 1 million episodes and it's been
on for 30 years 48 hours
yes 2020 Dateline so it's not new it's
just I think that us talking about it
and having casual conversations has kind
of normalized it for a lot of people who
thought they had to keep it as a comedy
in the murder part because we should say
you're not joking about the murder no
they were laughing about the murder
that's right
help people understand exactly what you
do well we're kind of like it's like a
it's a conversation about the story so
we're not journalists in any way we
don't really have to say that our
listeners know that very well we are in
no way crime journalists or
professionals really we're almost like
it's like after The Walking Dead when
you talk about the show it's kind of
like we're talking about the case
conversationally as people who have been
paying attention for a long time so yep
you made it you're not doctors not not
psychology I mean people listen to this
in huge numbers and they take your
advice one of the chapters is called
call your dad you're in a cult yeah
that's right yeah that's your advice and
that's something we said once
yeah that's become advice in a way
that's a lot of us amazing what the
quotes on our where does the title that
you end the podcast by always saying
stay sexy and don't get murdered and
that's the title of the book what does
that mean in essence it we knew we had
to have a like a sign-off you know a
memorable sign-off and so we each just
said something and then that's basically
what tattooed on their arms have a
meaning to them I mean I think it's a I
think it's just kind of about you get to
do what you want in this life and and
survive and thrive and I don't think we
meant it and you know to be so
philosophical in the beginning but I
think that's what it's come to mean is
it's very catchy and the thing I like
too that you do is you humanize the
victims you know just the fact that take
the word victim out of it you really
tell us these people had a lives these
that people had people that cared about
them and I think that's so important
yeah I think when you watch these shows
that you know the true crime shows and
read the book
and you come at it from a place of
empathy and understanding that this
could happen to anyone you know it could
happen to you the way it affects their
families it's so important to come at it
from that place stay sexy and don't get
murdered is on sale today Karen and
Georgia are going to stay with us though
we'll be back in a moment and keep this
conversation going